i'm not sure if this one is pleasant
okay okay
what does the bible say about divorce
and remarriage
are adult
adult
well adultery and death the of the
spouse okay the only ground for
remarrying someone else
can you marry someone
who
someone
if someone who has been divorced
yeah okay
let me pray
father in heaven
there's usually a simple answer what
sounds like a complex question
tell me what to tell your people
in jesus name i pray amen
the bible has one clear reason for
divorce
one clear reason
adultery
the church may give you several more
are you with me
the bible has one clear
reason for the divorce that's adultery
you cannot divorce a woman because she
can't cook or because you know whatever
adultery that's why when you consider
marriage think twice
but once you're in it you're stuck are
you with me
but stuff's not a good word you in for
life
so think twice you can't jump in and
jump out
because she broke a fingernail you can't
do that now
adultery is a reason for divorce now
the bible element makes it very clear
the innocent party can remarry
the guilty party must remain single for
life
course it doesn't happen because we do
what we want the innocent party can
remarry but god prefers reconciliation
malachi 2 verse 6 the lord of israel
saith that he hateth putting away
calvary shows that god prefers
reconciliation to divorce
are you with me
but
adultery is the clear
biblical reason for divorce
the innocent party can remarry
the guilty party must remain single
so yes you can marry a divorced person
if you determine that the person has
been divorced and the person is innocent
because someone decides to divorce you
there's very little you can do are you
following me it doesn't mean that you're
a monster because you got divorced it
may not be your fault at all
so an innocent person can remarry or can
be married by someone but the clear
biblical reason for divorce is
adultery but the church allows others
presumably based on the bible
all right
but remember when the flood came they
were marrying and giving in marriage are
you following me don't make the desire
for marriage a god
there's some women let me pick on the
women that's all they think about
and they run into trouble they marry the
first man with the pulse are you
following me and they run into trouble
go on